so when you hear that title what comes
to your mind
sorry
not much just it's there's pure baby
mums out there and not much weddings
going on that's what the first thing I
thought of I know it sounds bad but it's
not mad it's real but yeah that's what
it sounded like to me yeah
did you find it was it like kind of like
oh that's a bit like rude or did you
find it to be rude or
no
no I don't think it was either just
different parts of life in it like okay
all right fair enough Wicked uh what
about you what do you think about the
title modern women prefer to me Mothers
than wives I think it depends on the
culture let's say the European women
would rather be a
a woman I think Americans and Brazilian
are going to be a mother priority became
the child became the first priority in
her life
as soon zero became a mother so it came
as the more responsibility there the men
normally have
so
it depends I would rather say like it's
not an option when you have a child
the whole society
you are the mother and in let's say if
you have a divorce and you are the one
walking away with a bad mother you are
so a lot of stigma in the society we
need to be the mother and the main
character of the child so do you think
don't you think men get bad stigma as
well when they walk away from their
children
not as much as women
yeah because because women don't women
don't really have the opportunity to
walk away like that and women women
intrinsically on uh you know
instinctively don't want to walk away
from children whereas a man basically he
could like for instance a man could
impregnate all the women in this room
and basically walk away whereas you're
going to be stuck with the embryo
growing inside you so again don't you
think men usually get a bad rep if they
walk away from their children not as
much as a woman I think like I would
love to be a father I would have ten
thousand children you'd love to be a
father and have ten thousand children
what if women naturally it's like you
think right we have this in natural
intrinsic like we want to be mothers
right however there's so many women kids
nowadays I mean so many girls were there
their will might as well be a graveyard
honestly so on one hand women want to be
with their kids but I feel like they
only want their kids if it's with the
right guy yeah
they're also one of the first people
that are like um they're most likely to
kill their kid within the first like
year or so there's some stat that's like
the most likely person that is to kill a
child in the first like year to two
years of life it's the bomb
yeah
[Music]
that would make sense because since
they're spending the most time with the
child and probably Charles I don't know
making them miserable getting them in
there so like obviously that's gonna be
the number one culprit that makes a lot
of sense so the lowest so depressed
after the the birth women is facing a
lot at the same time they need to keep
being wives they need to be professional
a mother a cleaner a cooker so do you
think it's hard okay do you think do you
think like on average or typically
women's lives are harder than men's
because you're saying all these things
yes we need to deal with the period once
in a month you guys have no clue what is
that so you think because you have a
period once a month that makes your life
harder than the typical man out there I
were given a simple expanded just to
prove you get three days off from work
because they could prove the kind of pen
you feel when you're in a prep period or
during the period and a man will die if
they had this pain monthly men don't
survive flu they would never survive
like they want to
you honestly think you honestly think
that women's lives are harder than men's
lives just because they have a period we
are born to be breeding to be the
carrier to be the the superhero in the
house like you need to be strong in and
who protects you who who traditionally
predict protects women we are made to be
the protectors we don't have no no no
listen who traditionally usually
protects women
it depends what we talk about in a war
let's say about like she said mans go to
the war but I wish we live in a world
that we don't have no you know
listen I'm not being mean but you're
just not answering the question at all
who usually protects women
I mean if if I uh if I need protection
I'm not calling the local women's
shelter I'm calling a man so let's talk
about the Vikings when their husbands
were away doing everything the women
were they were they were staying there
were farmers but they also could defend
themselves it's always a point of view
it depends where you're from are you a
viking I can defend myself oh but I I I
had I came from a strong woman if he
attacked okay if he attacks any of us
okay yeah honestly if any of these guys
in the room attacked any of us we do I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm gonna just say this
right now if I call the police and they
send me a woman I am pissed I am pissed
I don't want a woman to protect me I
want a man to protect me why why on
Earth would I call the cops and they
send me a woman it's like
I I'm stronger and taller than most
girls what are you gonna do I I call the
police for men I guess my point on the
Vikings is that when there's no other
option the the example that you gave is
that there was no other option the
Viking women when their men weren't off
at Sea they wouldn't just like go handle
the the Skirmish they would call their
husbands or the men in the in the tribe
but once the men are missing then yeah
sure they've got to defend themselves if
the other Vikings came back they're
stealing your women like if another
child okay
I really do want to answer the question
that he said because I feel like men men
and women have really hard lives like I
feel like with men they're consistently
you're not really allowed to show your
emotions like go out to cry you're meant
to be a protector that this thing says
levels to your like life that you're
meant to go towards and if you're not
doing those standards you're not really
seen as a man so it's kind of hard in
that sense and then with women it's like
oh you can't do this you can't dress
like that or like you think it's just so
much you can't do this you can't do that
most of the things that they can't do a
lot of women don't want to do
when you really think about it a lot of
people like for instance oh yeah uh oh
is there's discrimination people think
that women can't are not strong enough
to go and fight this or do these kind of
physical activities most of the time
other women don't want to do it they
don't want to I'm not fat I mean I'm a
traditional girl like I think I'm gonna
say I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not
going at you I'm not going at you but
I'm rebottling that point of like
um it's my point is this that being a
man I don't think a lot of women
understand the gravity of being a man
they just don't that's why you start
talking about a woman's life's hard
because she has a period that's that's
okay monthly and I'm a man monthly too
there's a friend do you do you
understand the threat of violence that
men have to face every single day do you
understand that
yes do you understand that if you have a
boyfriend or a husband or whatever he
has to protect you so therefore his life
is at risk all the time because you
never know who's around that next corner
if you two are walking down the street
and someone attacks you or whatever
something like that he's Batman not you
so you can think you're strong as you
are but you know that if if you have to
step in front of him to catch a bullet
for him you're not going to respect him
you're not gonna there's a that's
already destabilized that's not that's
not real life you know that and once I
was in a situation my ex-boyfriend I was
the one fighting with the guys were
trying to rob Us in Brazil what was he
doing that's why he's she was crying and
where's he at yeah
you said God knows because you don't
care because you look to him like right
like I had to save you could you look at
him the same after be honest I was the
one saving him at the time so let's say
this kind of man you're talking about I
wish we have more this kind of man but
unfortunately the new generation are not
this kind of man protector and and like
she said it's okay I think we should
talk about mental health about this
stigmas we need to break for a better
future do you understand so so with that
being said do you understand that a
man's life is probably harder than that
the typical man's life is probably
harder than the typical woman's life do
you do you agree with that
depends we still have a low salary we're
still not in there
politics we are not in charge and let's
say yeah because we suck at it yup yup
I'm gonna say it I'm gonna say it women
are worse in leadership roles than men
we're worse at it and if we are doing
the leader thing the men see us as men
honestly them kind of women find it hard
to find men have you ever had a female
boss did you enjoy it really most women
are not great bosses and so we deserve
less money
oh I don't know about that part I I
definitely do agree with that do you
think if you do a worse job you deserve
less money
I work with both genders and most of the
time when you want something to be to be
talked U.S command when you need
something to get done you ask a woman we
are so much more much tasked than men
see that sounds nice and that's the
narrative we've pushed right that sounds
really nice however you know what they
did one time or they they did this in an
episode right they they threw some women
on an island and some men on an island
and said survive for a TV show
and survive here let's see who can
survive better right the women they the
men
put themselves in a hierarchy right and
they said you do this you do that you do
that they had like running water in the
first day the women couldn't get done
they had to get saved in like two days
because they were literally about to die
women in general I'm not saying they're
on exceptions to this rule you know we
got we got my lady Oprah she got a
really cool talk show but in general who
are the billionaires of the world the
richest women in the world how did they
get to be the richest women their
husbands their husbands we there are
things that we are naturally good at
we're good nurturers right we're I I I
personally think we do good talk shows
however however I just think in general
when it comes to Building Society men
they they Dominate and they do the jobs
that are more needed in society and
therefore if you do a better job you
deserve more money thank you
Dee would you agree that men pretty much
build Society just like Pro was saying
pretty much
let's start that a man need a woman to
come through this world
can we talk about dogs give birth dogs
give birth listen listen this is the
thing yeah like every time I ask you a
question you always go to Vikings or
Guardians of the Galaxy or something
like like I'll ask you a straight
question because if you ask me a
question I'll answer you I'm not going
to talk about what I ate yesterday you
get what I'm saying so do when you think
about Society yeah or just think about
civilization whatever don't men usually
build everything more than likely just
men build everything
like for instance this building we're in
how many women do you think helped build
this building
how what about the roads what about the
cars I agreement what about the
protection
what about the fact that you can walk
about at night and feel somewhat safe to
walk about at night and travel like it's
because
their men excuse to build up stuff of
course we need to demand this but of
course we also need the women what I'm
trying to say like there is no gender we
survive without the other simple like
that you're trying to tell me who's more
important or but it's not it's not
really an important thing that's not
what I said I'll say that I feel like
she's feeling a little bit no no no it's
called a minute it's called minute but
like obviously you can think what you
think in it like but I do I actually I
do think men would be able to survive
without women if we take out
reproduction they would be able to build
societies and make Society run women I
just don't think can do that now you see
you see and again we see that in in the
experiment where they put the men on the
island and they put the women on the
island they said survive go right the
men could figure it out the women
couldn't so on a small scale we can
already see men can survive without
women do I think they would be as happy
no the men love the women they love the
women but from like a survival point of
view yeah I Will Survive I would say I
don't think it's a conversation though
because you have to reproduce to survive
so well you say you're gonna survive you
aren't going to survive but the the
question is is we're just in a
hypothetical situation so taking
reproduction out of it obviously for
human you know whatever but in this
initial situation if we just dumped if
the world was just men or the world was
just women for as long as it runs for
who would probably be more efficient at
survival well there's no question men
built the world they built the roads
they built the houses they build the
bridges they build things and women
build people so you need both that's the
whole point mom is that there's no thank
you in society to men like we often sit
on men as a thank you for for building
I think that we just pretend it isn't
true and that's the part that's that's
the part I disagree with you yeah but
what I just said is true but it's like
even even there's like there's always
pushback whenever we say that men do
something well it's always but what
about women yeah every time every time
that's true I'm looking back because
women have periods
but anyway
because you get really close and I know
yeah that's true that's true and that's
that's true like the majority of men
face a lot of rejection in in life as
well
and he makes them feel like
but women don't think about that side of
things either women will literally die
from that yeah women like guys get
rejected on things that are even outside
of their control
and there's no ISM for that or that's
like come on man like you can't really
say all because it makes you feel you
had a period so it makes you feel what
about the guys that you ignore the guys
that in your friend zone that would love
to date you that you don't ever give
them a chance for about how they feel
man they're not ready to get rejected
that's the issue when they feel that oh
I mean to you you need to say yes it
doesn't work like that they'd never ever
accept when you're not interested on
that it's something that hurts it's easy
and it's easy for you to say that
because you never have to live that life
I do of course we all get rejected
what's no once in a while you think to
the same do you think that you lived you
experience the same level of rejection
in dating that that average man does no
of course not exactly so you don't you
don't know how he feels because you
don't experience that and you put and
think about this how many guys have you
approached in this year
um three three yeah three
that's why me man
as many
as many just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible